the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay good afternoon so in the last
couple of weeks we've gone through some
you know some of the major human
capacities that you have and I have and
most people have most of them right
which are the ability to see the world
around us to attend to what's important
to learn lessons from life to remember
things while we sometimes forget things
and today we're going to talk about
another huge dimension of human
experience of the human mind of the
human brain language the ability to talk
to one another you know I can talk you
can listen and vice versa to read to
communicate in the ways that are so
remarkable our love our life is flooded
with language right that we hear that we
read and so on
so when psychologists try to sort of
divide up language into study of all
components they talk about comprehension
understanding what somebody says to you
when you're an infant or now as an adult
or reading text or producing speech
which you can do with your mouth by
speaking or you learn to write so you
can both comprehend and produce language
both visually and orally and a thing
that has you know greatly enamored
linguists to figure out is how a
language that we speak is endlessly
generative I'm not sure you can actually
calculate out how many sentences we
could possibly produce but just for fun
people have done stuff and they said it
would take a hundred trillion years to
memorize all the sentences we can
produce I'm not sure that's exactly the
right number but it's a lot right
because we can say a lot of different
sentences and understand what a person
saying it's a incredibly generative
system for communication one person to
another so when people in psychology
think about different aspects of
language levels of language they often
divided it something like this phonology
is the sounds of language that we hear
that we acquire as infants that we use
to speak to one another syntax grammar
and by this this isn't like school
grammar or not you know get the sentence
right it's just regret the understanding
of the organization of words and how
that changes the meaning of the sentence
syntax semantics what are the words mean
what are the groups of words mean
pragmatics
and we'll talk about each of these a
little bit sometimes you know a person
is sarcastic so they go you go that was
an awesome yes sir lecture yesterday in
psychology somebody could say that in
100 trillion years and uh and you go
yeah yeah right okay so that's the
pragmatics versus us semantics then of
course it's not just sentences there's
we have whole discussions and another
aspect of language we'll just touch on a
little bit today is their emotional
comprehension and production the tone
somebody speaks in the tone you produce
are also informative so as many aspects
of language
we'll start with so the base most basic
or phonology so phonemes are the words
that people used to describe two
building blocks of speech sounds so boy
versus toy are differ by one phonemes
phonemes are the building blocks of the
sounds of language human use about a
hundred phonemes across languages but
any given language only uses a subset
and this has really interesting
consequences of course a language could
only exist in the world if you could
understand those phonemes you know
phonemes that are understandable I'm
going to be part of anybody's language
but different languages through for
historical reasons have ended up using
different subsets of phonemes and we'll
come back to that when we're babies for
about the first six months of our lives
were Universal learners we know all the
phonemes and respond to all of them as
we become native language speakers and
listeners we become only good at the
ones that are used in our language and
our ability to even recognize the ones
that are not in our language disappears
you can get it back some but the older
the you are you never get it back fully
so we're universal learners at birth but
we become enslaved to the language that
we are native speakers of and listen to
within months of birth English is about
forty-five so it's meant more than a
number of letters we have and sometimes
people get confused a little bit letters
or phonemes they're not so you know hot
and cold have the Oh hot and the O sound
and cold are different sounds same
letter so there's many more phonemes
even in English when they say it's about
forty five depending on dialects you can
have a couple more a couple less so
again we're born to use all of them we
use them or lose
something we don't entirely lose it but
we can we're never as good if we try to
learn a distinction once we become older
than that humans understand speech at an
incredible rate the typical fast talking
is about 180 words a minute 14 phonemes
a second and a continuous speech stream
but people can go up to 250 words we're
incredibly fast language processors
incredibly fast language processors so
how do we roughly conceptualize in the
most simple way you know what we have to
do to to get to a word that we hear to
get to its meaning
well coup stick information comes to the
ear those are you know wave forms
physical things arriving at our ears we
sort of in some way figure out how those
correspond to phonemes and then map that
in some way to words that have meanings
in the world and the reason why
machine's understanding what you say is
shockingly hard to do a good job on is
for the following reason there's a huge
difference between a word by the time
your mind understands what it is and the
nature of the signal that arrived at
your ear so we talked a lot about that
in terms of the retina and vision right
you have this very impoverished stuff
that arrives on your retina and then the
whole rest of your brain you know
millions and millions of neurons and
synapses reconstruct what's out there
from a very impoverished retinal input
and the same thing happens in audition
what gets to your ear is incredibly
impoverished and the rest of your brain
has to brilliantly reconstruct what it
heard and assign it to meaning and so
part of the challenge of your mind and
brain to do that is this this is a
representation of something like the
physical signal that arrives at your ear
and you could say well here's one word
here's another word what's the problem
okay but this is all the signal that
arrives that you're weird for the word
captain so here's the see all this stuff
for the a a period of long silence that
sets up the P okay turns out I'll
convince you of this in a moment that
our speech is full with in words of
silent breaks that are incredibly
informed
and alter our perception of what's
physically going on then the little T is
long stuff for the AI this long stuff
for the N so the physical signal to your
ear you know barely resembles what seems
like a single unit captain right and
where is that pause when person doesn't
say cap or doesn't say cut one two three
pertain right okay but I mean but the
pause is happening and it's incredibly
informative as I'll show you so that
that's the incredible thing your your
your auditory system your language
system has to reconstruct the sound into
phonemes into words it's not obvious
from the physics physical signal in the
year it's not even that a physical
signal at the ear gives you much
information at the outset about whether
you're hearing one word or two words or
three words so here is what and do you
mean as one big blend where is du
where's you words you mean and why does
what look so separate and these three
words what do you mean you know get all
garbled together and you have to unpack
them by your brain in mind here's
another example John said that the dog
snapped at them the dog snapped here's
what's coming roughly to your ear taken
from spoken speech and here again notice
that the boundaries that you can see
here the gaps of silence occur you know
not very related to the boundaries
between the words that your mind
ultimately understands so here's the
word the dog here's s4 snapped here's a
good pause but that's the pause between
the P sound and the T sound I mean that
looks like a good word boundary to a
machine that's a very good word boundary
okay it's not a word boundary for you
you know snapped as one word and here
comes at ad is kind of blended into the
T right so there's this physical signal
it doesn't even give you breaks where
words
separate from one another it's kind of a
continuous mix of breaks and silences so
here's to convince you that a silence
carries incredible information in it
let's see make sure I have the volume
okay so I'm going to play you this this
is
the physical signal to your ear the word
say say okay then they yeah okay alright
I always work as how there's an expert
in this and I'm almost like please Tyler
don't embarrass me when I'm wrong okay I
you don't have this pressure out there
but the teaching assistants are all
experts in something or another and then
they know more often than I do in that
topic and we hit their topic in the
course I'm looking over there nervously
okay so so here's say now they're going
to take this thing and just separate
this you know just just in the way you
do a physical signal computer just
separate in time they're just going to
add a little bit of time and what do you
hear say the T sound that makes is
simply adding silence here to produce
that now that's what you hear all the
time it's not a random choice but isn't
amazing that silence is as ultimately
informative for your mind as actual
language sounds themselves and now all
this is happening on the order of
thousands of a second and bits of
information that's bad enough here's
another amazingly tough thing so people
like to compare consonants that have a
lot of similarities but some interesting
differences ba and does it's really
comparing B versus deeds throwing on the
a just to have a vowel sound so here
again is a representation of what's
coming to your ear notice that all the
difference between the B and the D these
two consonants all the physical
differences occurring in 40 thousandths
of a second 40,000 so the second is all
the physical difference that you get as
you hear these two things
forty thousands of a second and yet you
know you can hear the word bad and
you're not going bad dab if you're one
of those thousands of the seconds right
and now that you'd be another word in
other word in a sentence that's why they
people use the word speech stream and we
think of it as a speech torrent right
phonemes phonemes phonemes breaks all
garbled together and your mind has to go
back and constantly instantly and
brilliantly figure out what you heard so
let me give you another example because
part of the challenge of this our
phonemes occur in the context of words
and sentences so make sure I have good
volume on this okay so let's do this
first one good what was that what okay
here's the same thing and a person is
going to say this now all by yourself
you got that right okay very saw the
three little pigs in the corridor okay
but here's the amazing thing
the first sound you heard I'll replay it
they took the word little and they cut
it out from the last sentence you heard
when little is said all by itself what
you comes to your ear is literally the
first thing you heard not this because
when you say a word in isolation little
people say it differently but we almost
never talk like that we almost always
have a sentence and it turns out the way
we say things and therefore the way you
hear things is hugely influenced by what
comes before it and what comes after it
nevermind things like the speed at which
different people talk the accent that
talk or the loudness of the background
conversation okay but just simply the
fact that you're going to say little by
itself and how does that work it's
amazing right listen again if you heard
little all by itself and it's exactly
the same physical signal
it's not so good okay let me try that
again
that's exactly the same physical signal
exactly the same physical signal as the
three bill days in the court are the
what you hear easily as little as
exactly that words in isolation and this
is a great demonstration if you hear a
word cut out the reason why it sounds
like nothing is your mind is already
preparing how to interpret that given
what you heard just before it and also a
little bit what you hear just after it
okay your mind is constantly fixing up
things because it knows what's going on
what's going into it what's coming out
is not because it just simply hears the
word itself if we lived in a world where
people just do one word every half an
hour you know we could do this in a
world where we're talking to each other
and sentences all the time we have to do
this here's another example of our
brilliant auditory system for hearing
these kinds of things so again these are
representations of how this physical
signal Arizer your ear hears the word
bet be boat and bird they all start with
the same B sound that's easy right but
look what it came to your ear look at
this signal this signal this signal look
at this one how different does this look
it's different because what follows the
bird influences how this is said but you
can see that you trends you translate
both of these into the B sound pretty
easily now look at these words these all
start with D look at how bet and debt
look almost identical we said it's only
40 milliseconds difference 40 thousands
of a second difference of physical
ignorant through your ear but you can
tell the word bet versus debt look at
that word D how different it looks from
word to word so your mind is constantly
figuring out what you're hearing the
problem of invariance and it's
constantly coming to you in incredibly
variable ways okay all right so one of
the tools we have and an amazing human
capacity is what's called categorical
perception so we have all this huge
range of physical sounds that can come
to our ear and kind of brilliantly and
you don't even think about it I mean
none of you go around bragging about
your categorical perception abilities
right like when you go to spring break
right
and you maybe some of you will go home
or you'll see friends and you won't go
you know I have categorical perception I
try to be modest about it you know but
it's it's an amazing human talent and
essential because what it does is this
we hear this huge range of sounds
depending on accents what comes before
what comes after and we have to decide
that's a B and we're going to do is take
this huge range of things and just go
boom it's a B or a D and that's all
there is to it so here's the way they do
it
so categorical perception sounds can
vary continuously we showed you some of
this continuity they in this experiment
on purpose they're going to vary sounds
in a very continuous physical way but in
our heads for ba and DA here in our
heads all the stuff that's over here
even though they're very different one
from the other at a physical specific
level we'll say ba I'm done with it
we're going to put it into one category
for interpretation and you're gonna have
a pretty sharp boundary here and
everything over here all these physical
Ignis you're going to call pas and so
you're not going to spend a lot of time
going that was a one third ba two thirds
pas probability if we couldn't do that
right because you couldn't get through a
word number - sentence you're going to
instantly group huge numbers of things
that are specific different from one
another into two categories that need to
be separated so here's the kind of
experiment they do I'll just give you
the feeling of it here's what they're
varying okay in constant units constant
units you know every stimuli is here is
different but every time you hear ba and
the constant going to vary something
about its physical property you always
call it a B and then something happens
in about 20 milliseconds of information
and boom you always call it a P okay
so change change change change change in
the physical signal you call it one
category a little bit more change boom
it's the other category and you keep
changing but for you it's always a
perfectly good P even those every one of
those are different alright
so it's an amazing fundamental capacity
to take a huge you know for all
practical purposes an infinite variety
of inputs and say it's a B or a P if
that's the world I'm working in syntax
that's another way in which we
understand things the way that words are
organizing
order so we could say the model embrace
the designer and the photo photographer
mentioned somebody sank to this but then
they complete the sentence the model
embraced the designer and the
photographer laughed okay so people who
study syntax really are interested in
what happens in your mind as you hear
the model embrace the designer and the
photograph photographer and some big
group hug is going on right and then all
of a sudden you get this word laughed
and all you've does it rearranged the
elements in your mind that's what syntax
is letting you do to say oh the meaning
is really quite different okay there's
only one hub going on and one person
laughing at them right but the meaning
it overtime is somebody talks to you set
up your thinking this boom because you
understand syntax you understand what
happened semantics are kind is more
straightforward we usually think about
them they're the meaning of words or
sentences morphemes and we can
understand semantics even when the
sentence is nonsense colorless green
ideas sleep furiously is a famous
example we can understand semantics even
in bad grammatical sentences right
fastly eat dinner or ball games start
soon you know your your fifth-grade
teacher would be up in arms to hear that
but you understand you know eat now go
see the ball game right okay so we get
through a lot of stuff to get semantics
and we can see interactions I stole this
example from Ted Gibson because it took
me like 20 minutes to figure out what
the sentence means you're probably
faster than I am you are you K funk I'm
going to the old man
we're where's the missing words or yeah
the old man the boats okay so you know
this is how you have to parse up the
sense it's not always obvious people who
study language love these things where
people are all confused most of our
lives we don't go through that much
confusion but there's some fun ones sort
of like the visual illusions to point
out how meaning and syntax can interact
as you figure out things here's another
example Jay Leno talked about sex with
Lyndsey lon
okay now wait a minute did I miss an
excellent episode of Jay Leno or or you
know was she on the show and talking
about safety and saying I'd rather not
talk about my recent conviction I'd
rather talk about something less
controversial okay
so um so somatic all these things are
constantly interacting in your mind is
kind of amazing when you think about
that right we said phonology is amazing
some
six syntax boom they're all happening in
you and none of you are sitting there
going just a phonology please don't ask
me to semantics you know we just admit
terms right brilliant so one of the ways
that people try to convince themselves
that these things are separable and
gives a little bit more insight as
evoked response potentials those are
these things that you can measure on
infants or adults that measure
electrical activity in milliseconds and
the speed of language processing surface
electrodes that give you an index of
hundreds of a few hundred thousand
neurons and this is an example you saw
before actually earlier in the course
the so called n 400 so n means whether
the wave is going up or down negative or
positive
400 means it occurs about 400
milliseconds about half a second after
the relevant event so here's this uh you
know let's see he it was his first day
at work as the baseline he spread the
warm bread with socks oh my gosh socks
semantically bad and here comes the n400
okay and the controlled condition is you
throw up this unexpected wear shoes
that's weird but not semantically and
you get it quite a different response so
here's an N 400 it seems to Sippy about
semantic expectation or congruence how
about if you mess up syntax the spoiled
child
throw the toys on the box and uh you
know then you get a response at about
600 milliseconds to syntactic and
congruity
so people this is just more evidence
that in the brain meaning or semantics
and syntax or something about word order
are processed somewhat differently in
time and place pragmatics is kind of fun
it's practical understanding right the
old joke do you know what time it is and
the person says yes they're messing with
your sense of pragmatics that you're you
know two negatives make a positive
saying oh yeah yeah I've heard that one
before earlier in the lecture now here's
something kind of interesting again
which is remarkable and if you didn't do
the experiment you could know that our
mind is like this because you wouldn't
do things like this except because it
sounds too ridiculous but your mind does
it all the time so we're going to think
about the word bugs
and I have to set you up a little bit
with paradigms you've heard before but
just remind you of these things
so one thing we one kind of task that
psychologists like to use to think about
how people process words is a lexical
decision tasks all you're deciding is
whether a word is a wheel word or a
nonsense word okay so dr. is real poplar
is not spy as a real word this spelling
is not a real word okay so a real word
not a real word we also talked about one
other idea really in the course that if
prior to processing a word like doctor
you get an unrelated word or a related
word you process doctor faster if you
had a related word before its semantic
priming the ideas about nurse overlap a
lot with the ideas about doctor and
seeing this word before makes you
process this word faster so you need
those two things in mind what was the
person doing is it a real word or not
and you're going to mess with what's in
their mind before that related or
unrelated and here's the experiment so
you would hear over headphones something
like this as an example rumor has it
that for years the government building
had been plagued with problems now
here's the critical sentence the man was
not surprised when he found several
spiders roaches and other bugs in the
corner of his room so there's two senses
of the word at least two meanings of the
word bug right the insect you don't want
in your soup at or the microphone that
somebody slipped into your room to
listen what's going on two different
meanings for the word bug this is
obviously about the insect so the person
is hearing this over headphones and on a
computer monitor in front of them after
they hear the word bugs here they see
for a lexical decision the word ant
which is related to this meeting or spy
which is related to the other meaning
that's not relevant for here or so which
is the control condition we'll ignore
that okay that's just a control
condition I'll ignore that remote so
you're making a lexical decision now on
the related meaning or the unrelated
meaning and here's what they find if
it's the related meeting and you only
have about a half second from when they
came on to when you had to do this task
so you saw the word bug and here comes
this you're you're faster
but if you get the unrelated meaning
within a half a second of processing the
word you're also faster what this means
is your mind has done exactly what you
would think it wouldn't do your mind has
looked up in your brain and in your
knowledge of vocabulary every meaning of
the word even the sentence is clearly
setting you up for the word the insect
meaning isn't every meaning of your word
is turned on and available to you your
mind does the opposite of what you might
think you might think well I know let's
look at the sentence you know I know
once I get spiders roaches and bugs by
here you know you're in the insect world
not in the world of spies right okay but
your mind even then looks up every
possible word because it's cheaper for
the mind to look up every word than to
start to decide what the reappropriation
other-- a second and a half
you're only fast for the selected
meaning and now you're slowed down for
the one that's not context relevant so
your mind looks up everything all the
time every every meaning of every word
you know every time that word pops up it
seems like your mind looks up every
meaning and then the rest of your mind
selects out the one that's relevant and
shuts down the ones that are not but you
wouldn't think that you'd think maybe
I'll just get the one I need I'm not
going to get everything it's like I'm
not gonna put all my clothes on walk
outside and take off everything that's
not relevant for the weather right all
right that seems like a really like a
you know inefficient way to get dressed
right but that's not the way your mind
is your mind it's cheaper and more
efficient to look up every meaning every
time and then pick the right one it's
more efficient and that's how people do
it so people use this word exhaustive
lexical access I look up every meaning
of the word and then I'll pick out the
correct one another another interesting
aspect of sort of that could be brought
into pragmatics and we'll talk a little
bit more about this later in the course
but emotional intonation and it turns
out where's almost all language
processes are left dominant as we've
talked about many times in the course
one stream of ass processing language
both visual and auditory
is right hemisphere dependent and that's
emotional intonation and that brings us
to our reading for today from Oliver
Sacks and I have to say I think Oliver
Sacks is a phenomenal author but there's
always been the sense of like hamat some
of these stories are just a bit too true
to be you know just a bit cute or
whatever it is and so for years I taught
for this story and I believe it's likely
true but I thought well it's just a
little cute and then came an experiment
that showed is it's not only cute but
it's exactly correct okay
so for this you appreciate this a bit
more if you if you know a couple things
about Ronald Reagan who was president in
the 1980s so what do you guys know about
Ronald Reagan what party was okay there
you go was he considered a good
communicator yes he was considered hey
you know you can have all kinds of views
and around Regas leagues the public said
he's an awesome communicator if I Barack
Obama said he would like to communicate
like Ronald Reagan all right whether
that's to get Republican votes or not
you know as here's your judgment but uh
but he was considered an excellent
communicator was he considered by and
large to be an extremely analytic
thinker might have been I don't know him
but not so much now part of this is the
prejudice or not these from California
and he was an actor before he became a
you know president and a governor
president he also had some degree of
well he ultimately had Alzheimer's
disease his question about late in his
administration whether he was already
working his way towards that so anyway
complicated things but he was master
communicator but not necessarily you
know the Barack Obama Bill Clinton Jimmy
Carter version of analytic power is a
general perception you never know
whether these are right or wrong but for
the person but in this story listening
to the president's speech are patients
with aphasia that Oliver Sacks described
and is getting laughter as they're
watching his speech and what happens is
some of the people with the left
hemisphere lesions they have a language
problem we see a video of that
pretty shortly they're laughing because
they sort of think he's that he's uh
that he's the way he's talking
his facial expressions they find
hilarious okay now why do they find it
hilarious they're not they have a damage
to the parts of the brain that help them
understand the content of his message on
the left hemisphere and here's what
here's where the sax thinks is going on
the feelings I have which all of us who
work closely with the physics have is
that they can you cannot lie to an
aphasic he cannot grasp your words and
so be deceived by them but what he
grasps he grabs with infallible
precision namely the expression that
goes with the words that total
spontaneous involuntary expresses this
which can never be simulated or faked or
words alone or words alone can hide all
sometimes too easily so you know when
you give up very public speech
especially under tough circumstances the
president sometimes have to do you know
we sometimes things are the tension
between exactly what they're saying and
exactly what they're thinking
okay and what they feel they need to say
and exactly what they know behinds
behind the scenes and so the idea is
that these are faces were feet where
they were saying you know this guy
obviously doesn't mean what he's saying
look at his face look at his tone I
don't know what he's saying but it's
hilarious how he's masking his face and
speaking in a funny tone to tell
something he truly doesn't believe okay
that's their interpretation and yet he
has an opposite patient a patient with a
right hemisphere lesion we said that's
the side of the hemisphere that seems
important for facial expressions and
emotional intonation and she complains
about the logic of the case he's making
as if having normally we talked to
somebody's both left hemispheres getting
the content analyzing the content right
hemispheres something about the
intonation true or not true whether they
are their eyes like this and they can't
even face us as they tell us something
they know is false okay so but these
patients may be because they have one
channel of information knocked out
because of injury to become hyper
sensitive to the other one all right so
I thought well that sounds fantastically
you know interesting but you know is
that really true so here in Boston they
did a study with a large number of
patients that's the superior
identification of people who are lying
to you
they had they had made video clips and
audio clips of people who are lying to
you if they had a left hemisphere lesion
so this is a paper
so here's the two examples so they have
an example let's pick this one we're
both you see you see just a facial
expression of a person talking the voice
is turned down your job is to decide
whether a person is lying or not okay
and some videos are lying some videos
they're not so how would you do well I
don't know how you would do but I can
tell you how a group of Harvard
undergraduates did 50% is chance and
here's how they did okay that was one of
their control groups and in fact for
studies like this they brought in many
many kinds of people to ask whether
anybody is better everybody's pretty
much terrible at directly telling
whether a lie is going on now these are
video clips of people you don't know in
circumstances you don't know that could
matter but everybody is terrible at that
policemen are terrible FBI agents are
terrible the only group that seems to be
above chance and not much above it our
Secret Service agents okay so if you're
a friend with a Secret Service agent and
you wanted to see them you know keep in
mind that they seem to be above chance
or not awesome they're above chance but
Luke was doing better than everybody
patients were the left hemisphere
lesions and the interpretation is all
the content of the lie is gone all they
see is your expression or your
expression and intonation and because
that's all they have to go on they can
tell more when you have the discomfort
of lying than a person who's partly
persuaded by hearing the message you're
sending as you talk so I thought this
was an overly cute example but it turns
out to be exactly replicable in a full
study any question about that okay so
let's talk a little bit about the brain
basis of language we've talked a little
bit about you know we know that if you
have damage here you have Broca's
aphasia on the left hemisphere trouble
producing language damage here
Wernicke's aphasia trouble comprehending
language to a first approximation and
and there's a lot of research that has
made this much more complicated but to a
first approximation the lesions are in
frontal cortex or temporal cortex the
speech in these patients are what's
called non fluent or telegraphic they
get single words out but have a hard
time
anything like a sentence can be very
frustrating for these patients
Wernicke's patients seem much happier
you'll see a film in a moment their
speech is fluent but it's amazingly
empty of content okay
these patients have trouble producing
speech for their comprehension is decent
these patients produce speech pretty
well but their comprehension so they're
sort of mirror opposites and let's see
what I want yes so in this field a
frequent incredibly frequently used
picture to study aphasia is this
specific picture it's called the cookie
theft picture why it's become widely
used I'm not exactly sure but once it's
widely used enough that everybody uses
it okay so they'll put a picture like
this in front of the fit of an
individual and they'll ask them to
describe what's going on is to elicit
production and you know you would say
something like you know here's you know
there's two kids the kids down a stool
oh they're gonna fall over because you
know they're falling off the cookie jar
and the mother sort of not paying
attention her mind must be somewhere
else because she's letting the water
splish-splash here right that's what
you'd say something like that okay so
let's see what patients with aphasia say
and other examples of their difficulty
with language
yeah the writing tends to go pretty much
with their spoken language okay that's a
really good question about so the
question is what would the writing be
like it very much parallels their spoken
language yeah
sorry
okay so this week very good question
cannot could not fluent aphasics learn
sign language to bypass in a sense their
problem right so I'm about to answer
that in a moment right on the next slide
not directly that but the implication of
that right okay because the important
thing is so let me show you this thing
let me come back the question is you
know could you train an aphasic to use
sign language to get around because or
her language problem right if it's a
speech problem so people have studied a
sign language as a language for many
reasons but a huge one is this because
I'm going to interpret your question the
way I need to and then you can tell me
if I did it right for from your
perspective versus in what sense is
language equal speech right because
could could you communicate
linguistically like but just switch to
your hands if for some reason and the
answer is that at the level of the
problem of these patients they could not
do it because they're these kinds of
patients the problem isn't really speech
there are people who can't forgive
problems with the motor apparatus to
move their mouth that does exist their
problem is in language processes that
produce your speech intent okay or
language processes that extract meaning
from sounds and those language processes
that produce what you want to say that
comprehend what you hear or read those
are the same ones that are utilized as
far as we understand whether you're
producing language in the typical vocal
way or in the less typical but well
studied way of sign language that makes
it okay so you can't get around it
because it's a language problem so both
by brain imaging evidence for example
here are patients who use sign language
turning on Broca's area and Wernicke's
area on tasks that are about
comprehension and productions the same
areas whether it's using your hands for
sign language or using your mouth to
talk or your ear to hear further they've
been really fun studies where they took
deaf infants and have shown and it's not
easy to show up but I think most people
are convinced that they babble with
their hands the same way babies make
little sounds to get themselves going
we'll talk more about infants in a
moment infants who grow up in an
environment where they only learn sign
language
bable with their hands because speech
you know language is not about your
mouth talking it's about ideas that you
can communicate by your production or
comprehension by your hand over your
mouth so language is separable from
speech because even without speech you
communicate in very much the same way in
terms of sign language by many studies
yeah like an action words since either
against or that they also couldn't like
it magic words are like cupen the people
with the Broca's area
I don't think so III you know we talked
to us before that I may not be
understanding your question exactly
but that in many ways imagining
something is the same part of the brain
that does it when we imagine a face we
turn on the parts of our brain that sees
I think when you imagine if you if you
sit I do this sometimes I say here's
what I'm going to say to that person in
my head okay and I practice that little
speech that's this part of the brain
pretty much running okay just another
this is a last little step of moving
your mouth but that's from the
discussion we're having now that's kind
of a superficial thing of moving your
mouth okay that's not speech planning
speech thinking speech intentions those
are a core process for production for
comprehension and I think imagined stuff
this is exactly the same way right is
that okay yeah yeah
how what is your thinking
yeah it's a good question is if there
are so that if they have this troubles
with score language ideas abilities
what's the thinking light I can just
tell you that it's a sort of a classic
debate for humans how deeply language
equals thought but language now and in a
sense of speech okay it's just one of
those things that people debate a lot
because it depends what you mean by
these things in many different ways but
but if language means something like
comprehending ideas in the world it's
hard to get around that for thinking
about it it means planning actions in
the world that changed the world around
you and communicating that it's hard to
to do to not have that capacity for
thinking in that way right so it's at
this level not whether use your hands or
your mouth it's very hard to separate
out what you might call thought and what
you might call language but keep in mind
that these patients that we see you know
it's not like they lost all of language
at all so even though the Broca's
aphasic cross child producing language
he's produces some and he comprehends it
pretty well so it's not like these
patients have lost all of their language
circuitry and therefore don't have
thought available right they have a lot
of language left in their head and a lot
of thought left in their mind is that
okay um so one interesting thing that
people have wondered where a brain
imaging gives us evidence that we
couldn't have imagined you know 15 years
ago is this so you had if you have
damage let's say here's a patient with
damage to the left frontal area and they
get better because they've had a stroke
here or an injury here they get better a
question that people have wondered is do
they get better by sort of somehow
recovering ability and the part of the
brain that got injured or do they get
better because they use an entirely
different pathway in their brain now
until brain imaging you couldn't begin
to touch that question but now we have
some evidence then I'll make it just but
so here's an example of a patient who
has damaged here they have him do a task
that in healthy people turns on exactly
that place and when he does it he can do
it okay and where does he do it in his
right hemisphere so this patient seems
to switch which hemisphere he uses for
language it takes time and training to
recover that but it seems like he's
found an alter
pathway to produce the language somehow
turns out that the more people have
studied these things are more
complicated it gets maybe just diversity
of people the diversity of injuries or
whatever so it doesn't always work this
way but often it seems like when people
have better recovery from a large injury
to the speaking left hemisphere they
find a way somehow through practice and
training to get the right hemisphere to
take over some of those responsibilities
okay language acquisition so one of the
most amazing things about infants right
is they go from zero to speech in just a
couple of years and go through an
unbelievable training and the program of
development so what happens in two or
three months they perceive all the
phonemes they notice this change in
phonemes by six months they start to
ignore distinctions among sounds that
are not used in their language and was
other language sounds they start to
babble that's getting there in some way
getting their speech ready to go by
eight months they start to identify
single words in a speech stream in a
year they're back there babbling becomes
more adult-like sounding but about a
little bit after that they get up to
about fifty words in understanding so
comprehension always goes ahead of
production you know children understand
words before they could speak them but
then the lagging here comes a speech
telegraphic speech short sentences at
two years and then you know finally
pretty complete speech in many ways by
nine so it's a long long process
learning you know ten thousand words
estimated by the age of six is a
spectacular learning curve when they do
experiments on infants where they
measure things like preference or
learning by sucking rates and a nipple
because they can't talk they're trying
to figure out what is the infant hearing
within two hours of birth they suck with
more enthusiasm to their mother voice
over another voice these are infants
this is their first visit to their
mother and half you have to sign up to
do this experiment you know that now
they might have heard their mother's
voice in a certain way in the womb right
so this it's not the but they already
have picked up by three-day-old
they prefer language to many other
sounds like music now we come to love
music but that's not the urgent business
of the infant okay by four days old they
start to notice
and says between languages this is
amazing right there the the rate of
learning is fantastic and by two months
they can tell the Baga distinction you
know subtle distinctions forty
milliseconds information and then they
develop a continuingly strong preference
for the sounds of their native language
now some years ago people debated
endlessly this left hemisphere
specialization for languages is
fantastically essential and striking in
humans does that grow over time or is it
in your mind and brain at birth
okay and the evidence is pretty
compelling from many sources but here's
maybe the most here's fMRI on
two-day-old infants you might ask how do
they instruct the infant's to lie still
in the scanner and participate in the
experiment and the answer is at two days
old infants mostly just lay there and
don't do much okay all right I mean you
know I said I mean they don't they don't
do much and he's a lot going on their
mind but they don't have much physical
apparatus to do much say you could
swaddle them very warmly you just lay
you know you put them on a cradle into
the fMRI scanner their parents have
signed up they you know for them and you
can play them sounds where they just lay
there and do nothing they can't push
buttons they can't do stuff but you can
see what's happening inside their brain
and at two days old here's the left
hemisphere response to language compared
to the right so it's there as you know
instantly we believe it's been there
actually in the womb as the child's been
developing though this left hemisphere
genetically set up dominance for
language and almost everybody fMRI just
for those of you who yeah you get again
we can start doing it at about age five
but from about three months to age five
it's incredibly hard to do children in a
scanner but the first couple of days
it's not so hard now a really
interesting a line of research has
talked about motherese have you heard
this term so how do how do grown-ups
even college students talk to babies you
talk to babies just like you talk to
everybody else No
cute baby baby baby you know what
everybody looks like an idiot right okay
alright and you can just think okay
that's just people being idiots around
babies but it turns out there's been
beautiful beautiful studies to show that
what you spontaneously do this and you
know I do you and I don't take motherese
or father ease courses right what we do
spontaneously is that way of elongating
sounds the intonations we give our
incredibly perfect to help the baby
learn language we're exactly doing what
they can understand okay and that at
that again must be virtually in our
genes I think it's you know we hear it
around so it's not zero but the short
pauses careful enunciation exaggerated
intonation baby view that's you can do
an experiments where you take language
and you get rid of those and the babies
are like they don't know what's going on
they're not interested you put them back
in boom those are perfect for the baby
okay
that's amazing not only how babies are
ready to go
but how adults who talk with them are
ready to go I mean it's just amazing
okay it's you know none of us will ever
be as good a teacher in a classroom as
all of you will be with a baby anytime
you talk with them right it's just
amazing so there's beautiful experiments
that show that every time you tinker
with the way that mothers spontaneously
or parents spontaneously talked to
infants you make it worse less
interesting and less informative for the
infant so now let's talk about a more
formal experiment to sort of these are
they sort of the classic experiment that
nailed home this message that at Birth
were Universal under standards of all
sounds in the world as the years go
along we become only good at the sounds
that are relevant that are part of our
own language a famous example you know
in the u.s. it's a difficult difficulty
for Japanese native speakers for the r.l
distinction but every language has some
distinctions that doesn't make and
they're really hard when you get older
so here's the idea in English we make a
distinction between ba and DA and by 10
to 12 months and infants can make that
distinction and certainly adults can
that's categorical deception that we
talked about that kind of division
between Banda
but their sounds that occur in other
language so was shown here and you're
going to hear some of you may know Hindi
sounds and it'll be different experience
for you when I every year when I first
hear this clip I'm about to show you I
think something's wrong because they say
the infant's going to tell the
difference between da and da and I go
well how they going to I can't do that
okay that's because there really are
different sounds they're hearing but in
English they're not different sounds and
so it all sounds the same to me
I'm the longer universal learner you
know haven't been since quite a while
okay so here we go
understand always by the brilliance of
the infant you know researchers like
this who somehow pretty convincingly in
most cases you know really tell you what
the infant is knows or pays attention to
our thanks and pretty compelling ways
even though they can't tell you
themselves um so so one thing that's
come up in the u.s. I mean the whole
world is a kid you know becoming
evermore bilingual and trilingual there
used to be some concerns less now and
I'll tell you you don't have to worry
about it whether it's bad to learn to
language that once when you're a kid and
some parents worry about this right
you're going to be all messed up because
you're going to blend them all up and
not do well in school and so there's
been quite a bit of research actually
asking tracking and asking whether
there's any downside it is huge upsides
to knowing two or three languages are
there any downsides in terms of language
development and the objective evidence
is pretty compelling that for babbling
for first words for first picture four
pairs of words at a Sun things at two
months that there's really no cost so
they followed in Canada for example
children who grew up learning English
and French English and ASL French and
for English only everybody does the same
pretty much there's no cost okay
compared to the huge gain sometimes some
kids will get a little mixed up they'll
actually mix up languages because
they'll just get mixed them up when
they're pretty young but there's no
developmental delay or milestones or
negative consequences there's only the
benefit of having you know two or three
languages that you could speak so the
evidence is overwhelming empirically
that there's no cost for learning more
than one language at a time when you're
an infant um one thing there is a cost a
little bit if you're a boy okay so
unknown why this happens I mean that I
don't things any deep science about it
but everybody has observed that for
example number of new words understood
during the first two years of life that
girls on average outperform boys and
language acquisition early on and then
things get you know closer pretty much
but the rate of learning on girls and
averages is faster than boys nobody I
think understands the specific basis of
that so people talk about critical
periods in language acquisition you know
and what are fragile or resilient
aspects of language where language is
that
aspects of learning languages seem very
dependent on the age you are which are
independent so phonology including the
production of the language sounds seems
very fragile easy when you're young
harder when you're older grammar is also
age sensitive making subtle grammatical
distinctions learning about meaning or
vocabulary
you're perfectly fine when you're an
adult that doesn't seem to show
something like a sensitive period and
here's one famous study that you know
that established some of these things
they looked at what age people arrive to
different countries from different
countries to the US that started
learning English that people didn't know
English before and then they had them do
they're all adults now and they had to
do quickly grammatical judgments and
what they found is if you came to the US
when you were born in the US you came to
the age three to seven you know you were
very good at doing this but the later
you came here eight to ten years of age
11 to 15 17 to 39 your ability to make
these vast subtle of grammatical
judgments you know just went down even
though you've been here in many cases
for many years you're very smart accents
are like that right people come to the
US at a certain point in their
development they're very skilled in
English and big vocabulary but the
accent never disappears that's another
thing in the terms of language
production that has this fragile
developmental early period so the last
thing I'll do and then show you a movie
for about eight minutes you know one of
the sort of we get these occasional sort
of horrible experiments it's not even an
experiment of nature which is an
experiment of horrible human behavior
and the most famous one in language
development which had a huge impact on
the field at the time is as a child
Genie I'll show you see her in a movie
clip in a moment they discovered her a
lock in a root
room in a house from age 20 months
approximately until they discovered her
at 13 she was she almost spoke to no one
so the people taking care of her locked
her in a closet basically and do not
talk with her or she had no language
interactions until they she was
discovered and rescued and then they
performed research for years saying what
could she could she learn things what
could she not learn
she got single words for example but she
never got particularly good at grammar
so either syntax you know sort of brutal
way to test the idea that what's
acquirable later in life and what if you
don't learn it early in life it's been
possible to acquire fully so all in
would this will do this for like five
minutes or seven minutes
got there its summarized in your book
it's you know everybody knows about it
because this is a study couldn't do
epically in a million years right he
would never do which is if you deprive a
child you the critical period of
language exposure and she never got lots
of aspects of language going
she got okay and you know a minimal
vocabulary grew in other ways but many
of the things that come from a language
perspective she never got machine miss
secretary so that's a bit of a sad story
obviously but have a good Spring Break
been a refreshing spring break and I'll
see you ten days
you
you